the man is an idiot he is a complete
buffoon and an idiot but there are other
people that are realizing this besides
me so the CEO of JP Morgan Chase Jamie
dimon and he's been a big player in our
economy for many many years Joe Biden
often quotes him as a friend and someone
that he turns to for guidance and that
understands the economy and all that
well even now uh he is going Joe you're
kind of screwing up the whole freaking
thing there have been a lot of Lehman
comparisons made in recent weeks and
months with regards to the Fallout from
the energy crisis you are the only Wall
Street CEO who is around to navigate the
global financial crisis how worried are
you about Europe this winter given
everything that's going on in Ukraine
and with the energy Supply well I think
we're getting energy completely wrong
which is you know ever since this war
started you've known that Europe is
going to have a problem and that it was
pretty predictable that Putin was going
to cut off some gas in certain oil an
oil price would go up and by the way for
the climate folks here it's made the
climate worse because people have this
bad assumption that high oil prices and
gas prices reduce consumption reduce CO2
no poor Nations India China Indonesia
Philippines Vietnam are turning back on
coal plants as are rich Nations called
Germany Netherlands France we have it
completely backwards and in my view
America should have been pumping oil and
gas and it should have been supported
you know we're trying to have our cake
and eat it too a little bit okay so
before I get to JB diamond and it's like
man it's just obvious like again it's
some of this is so obvious in politics
when someone is just reading talking
points often reading them poorly off the
teleprompter for someone that is an
expert in their field you may not like
Jamie dimon all of his uh decisions
related to what he's done with JP Morgan
or whatever but it's like the guy
obviously knows he's doing but before I
get to that I tried to write out a bill
what was it a billion trillion times 50
million and I ran out of room on the
paper it's just it's just a lot of zeros
I don't know what this number is but I'm
pretty sure it's not even the number
that Chief Joe just had that much money
people we could fix this thing anyway
Diamond makes a couple interesting
points one of the problems that we have
in America is that we have an extremely
myopic view of the world that if only we
just gave more money to climate we could
fix the whole thing as Diamond points
out you know these other countries in
other parts of the world India China
with all of these people you know
there's a lot of people in India and
China and they're going through their
industrial revolutions you know
currently while we did it you know say
50 60 70 years ago they're turning too
cold now so we could do everything we
could do everything you could never use
a plastic straw again and I hate those
freaking you know what I'm talking about
those those cardboard straws and then
have you been to the places where they
have the the pasta ones they I've been
to a place I think I think it was was
Italy maybe where they had the pasta
straw so it works for a couple sucks and
then you're just sucking on a wet noodle
is that what you people want you see
what I'm saying that's the future that
Joe Biden wants everyone's going to be
sucking on wet noodles your water tastes
like pasta
calm down Dave okay the point is that
whether we do everything that AOC and
Joe Biden wants and whether we wreck our
economy in the name of green energy and
all of those things not only will it not
fix anything it will harm our economy
and the rest of the world will still be
using coal and fossil fuels and all of
this stuff so it's just like it's just
the fact that Diamond's even saying this
knowing that he is one of the guys that
Biden is always referencing Biden is
always my my buddy he says it all the
time my buddy my friend Jamie Diamond he
even said this
well I have a feeling that Joe Biden if
he's awake right now he's not too
thrilled uh with uh Mr Jamie Diamond